Teheran, im Jahr 2018.
Wo früher noch vielfach der schwarze Ganzkörper-Schleier
Tschador üblich war, sieht man heute viel Haar.
Seit dem Amtsantritt des moderaten Präsidenten
Hassan Ruhani im Jahr 2013 gibt es immer weniger Sittenpolizisten auf den Straßen.
Früher achteten sie streng auf die Einhaltung
der Kleidungsvorschriften in der Islamischen Republik.
Im Januar sorgte eine Internet-Aktion für
Aufsehen, bei der Iranerinnen Selfies ohne Kopftuch posteten.
29 Frauen wurden festgenommen.
Seitdem diskutiert das Land wieder einmal
über die Kleidungsvorschriften.
"Das ist keine breite Protestbewegung.
Wenn Sie Frauen fragen, ist es für sie O.K.,
den Hidschab zu tragen, wenn sie ihn so tragen dürfen, wie sie wollen.
Nur eine kleine Minderheit ist ganz dagegen
und feindselig."
"Wir tragen den Hidschab vor Männern.
In unserem Land wachsen Männer mit der Vorstellung
auf, dass Frauen den Hidschab tragen.
Unter diesen Bedingungen werde ich den Schleier
in meinem Land niemals abnehmen."
Andere Frauen sind gegen die Vorschriften.
"Jeder sollte selbst entscheiden, was er trägt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein paar Locken jemanden
provozieren können."
Eine Umfrage der Regierung will unlängst
herausgefunden haben, dass nur noch 40 Prozent
der Iraner die Durchsetzung der Kleidungsvorschriften
unterstützen. 2006 waren es noch 15 Prozent mehr.